こっちです俺肇社長みんなも知ってるかわかんないんだけども
うぇい肇社長わーまあ世間で言う五人なんですよねやっぱり偉人ってのは石像をつくっ
てナンボなんで今日は職員の日かにちょっと手伝ってもらって会始めして上の石像を
作ろうと思います
行ってみましょう
ロスくっていただく
直近ぬーんって言ってこちらを一対一で0
れを渡ったものが今こちらに状態になります
h 賞吉田氏こちらこそてよ
元ん
ここ混ざって水を
うわあああああ
したらこういった
なあ
5位
ええええええ
美味しいこれじゃなかったじゃないですか入っていません
混ぜてみます
[音楽]
は結構かかっ
重たいですよねばいばい
ああすごいめちゃ巻号
4日
もう大丈夫だと思いますはい
[音楽]
ありがとうございましたええええ
思想
まさにこれは僕ですか
ああああああああ
の先にいつの基盤的なものを作っていただいているということでそうでさ
ありがとうございますでは
排気音そこであのちょっと水化していくんですけどあーおれが店店主ここに愛と
を守る壁はい
これを統計縫い付けてくださいはいて行
厚みは結構薄日に1回少しずつ集めてあのいっぺんにつけるとですねも得たるが男を
通じぬんでそれを少しで作った
続けていきます
3周これツルツルしてるので塗りづらいと思う大変こういう形ではい
ちょっとやってみてみてくださいねっ
うわーこれはヤバイ落ちますよねそうですね塗りづらいんですよ
デザインですよね
落ちましたはぁ
[音楽]
焦燥をちょっとも付ける呉西難しいですよね
をしましたら
少し力を入れてあーあーもーしょんそうですね
まあ落ちちゃってのいいよないを下に板を超えていただけます
[音楽]
00分
停的に顔にプールカードを分析
このこっちがよく目を持ちます
goo
[音楽]
その皆さんの想像してる60万円ムズカせん
を欠航しつけたほうがいいですよねそうですね地下ガチャ
はい
[音楽]
ここらへんもでしまう感じです
耳になります
うーんんじゃないですか
金ございますやべっ
他の私鉄花とかどう種子島したら肌なんかはですね
小さいやつでちょっとつけてあげて
ので穴をつくった方がん
[音楽]
ああ
プロポーズはプレゼン多くてもいいあー
記述連続ていれば皆さん大きくしちゃってくださいハイタッチつどんどん大きくでき
ます
どうですかねぇ
アズラン寿司
[音楽]
ちょっとまだ不細工ですねね
えっ花や木がも違うユニット肌になってます
[音楽]
naonao
あ頭に耳をつけている女子期待というの明かりを叩きつけている
米ん
[音楽]
何もおじいちゃんみたいなというふうなこっから少しずつゲームになっていただきたい
ポインタもやってい
あい記念すぎてって
[音楽]
ん
を見つけていきます1
入ってがぁああ
私はこれくらいでいいのではいこの耳を
れています
はいいうちょっといいですねぇー
ちょっと上でも
[音楽]
2月が降りました指針を作った方がいぬっちみっぽいのに
僕が作った方わー
じゃあ ameba ナビ民に引っ付いたり気になったらこんな
違うんですよ
にゃ than
[音楽]
見た目に動かせるん
使いません
柘植ぜひ行ってるんです
理由で打ち勝っ
タイトルですね
[音楽]
シャーリーん
三重終了しました一緒なんでしょうねはぁ
me
ティーマのクラブ
それくらい hai
wh
[音楽]
me
wh
絶対前ぐらいですね
ん
みんな難しそう安全に三いないんです
goo ん
ん
ああああああ
0 tb ja nai
ということが写真ももう涼感をまっせいます
襲った
ん
ぷっ
高等部難易度がすごい
[音楽]
た
うわああああっあっー楽しいだと思うん
[音楽]
美容室で失敗したはじめしゃちょーくらいまでははっはー
相次ぐに準ずるシールでございまーされておりますありがとうございました
[音楽]
ブーバーし
もよろしくお願いしますどうぞよろしくお願います
そうですね
ブーブーをあ今日はティロンえへん金入っ難しいちょちょしけで読めます
最初にシーラーいう
そうですけどもうちょっとだけ窯に火をつけてはいっ
[音楽]
結構こうやって持っているようなそのようにして全体的にちょっと入ってもらえたと
思います
浅田もう
そうです体が出てくださいはいっ
ん
多分全部塗りました設置増加でていますが少しずつ中広がそうしてねでは次は
ゴースになる色しましょうハイ sp なる井戸は
ありこれを塗ります
ちょっと先にクローグルですねさっきみたいな形で打ってみてください
明日も会が手にとってくださいで真っ黒にも釣れますよ赤岳刷毛ですね真っ黒に振っ
失礼します
減少彼らはないですか
[音楽]
わからん
可愛い務めないん
[音楽]
よしできましたなんかまだ銅像君が押しましたねそうですねまた違った表情になってい
ただけでは
ダイエット次に大衆的なバグりの高典略でしょう
いよいよですね4やらじゃん
今後長が議論になるでしょうかところでなるほど
ズバリああ
金色ですねとボタンお席ぞならず金のソート装い金
上を吹きかけて黄色にしてくださいはい
いきます
[音楽]
し結構が降っています
酢はスゴいドッグ t you do
裏返していはい数
そうでないかねぇ
もっともちょっと毎日履いているようです
[音楽]
します
してもフランス義眼小学なった奴ははぁ
そんな感じで配筋の元気なあはじめちょっとになりましたね完成ですか
そうですねられるが使ってみました
安定しました続チャーがちゃんと作ってるっていう
髪型が僕のちょっと短い時みたいに貼ったりの共同作業
そうですねそういうわけで無事肇社長の金どうぞ
歓迎しましたーー
jr 敵ターン本当に職人さんのおかげでございます
はいの爆発どれかにー
ああああああああ
[音楽]
た
[笑い]
市場が届けてくださいました
はいという流れで肇社長の金の像が家に届きました
届けてくださった司書本当にありがとうございますで今回なんねそもそもこの入る社長
の金の像を作るような
誰かといいますとなあグレー地で歴史に名を刻んだと思って頭作ったの一つリューター
と思うんですけど
作っている時にもよく飲んでたと思うんですけども土手下みーさんが職人の皆さん応援
しているということで今回この首相と一緒に像を作ることができました
文民さんあれ登山車この日のぞあは部屋のどこかに飾らせていただきたいと思います
みんないたずら違いで a